[Music]
good morning John it's Monday August
13th yeah what day is it gonna be a fun
day good morning John it's Monday and
I'm Stephanie one to hate it because I
can't think right now because I'm
sitting right now really I gotta keep my
eyes on God just watching that makes me
nauseous
we went to the fair here's more fair
let's see we've got regular-sized flower
arrangements we got miniature flower
arrangements we've got zucchinis dressed
up like Mussolini we've got zucchinis
dressed up like Pig got zucchinis with
intricate carvings in them zucchinis
dressed up like I don't know what this
thing is
we've got giant zucchinis and good sized
pumpkins and another zucchini that's
dressed up like something I've never
seen before and there's white eggplants
and zucchinis just like penguins and
inappropriate messages for children and
then Katherine and I watched sheep
showmanship where people show sheep and
win prizes for showing sheep Ashleigh
Iverson in her gigantic lamb won first
prize in the professional sheep
showmanship class and earth there are
cows giant cows and goats and friendly
goats and chickens and chickens and
chickens and this I think is also a
chicken and there were turkeys and white
turkeys and bunnies and bunnies and
bunnies and bunnies their llamas and
there were llamas and Alana's and AH and
really ugly llama and there were bubbles
and a scary clown trash container and
there were tiny horses and shaggy cattle
and Buffalo look don't touch and funnel
cake and horrible horrible
nauseatingly gross evil giant rides that
I don't understand how anybody gets on
[Music]
up-and-down spinny spinny spinny spinny
and of course there's the man of Galilee
a 1969 Dodge Charger made up to look
like generally from the Dukes of Hazzard
that is actually an evangelistic tool
Montana
I love the fair I look forward to it all
year and it always lives up to my
expectations especially cuz mostly my
expectations are that there will be
fried food down to business I have one
piece of news that I need to discuss and
then I have to discuss your waxings um
there has been some discussion in the
forum about Stephen Colbert and how on
The Colbert Report last week the same
did it I did my video he did some
presidential anagrams just like I did
some presidential anagrams and in fact
kind of had a couple that were exactly
like mine the question is did he steal
it from me the answer is maybe
probably not John and I are pretty sure
that the show is filmed considerably
before I put the show online in any case
comedy should be free and if he did you
know borrow it from me that's more of a
gigantic ego boost than it is something
that I would feel bad about now on to
your punishment I don't care what kind
of happy meal you get but you do have to
blend it and eat it I don't care what
kind of drink you have with it just
blend it and eat it and as for the
waxing I feel like you've been such a
good sport with the whole blending of
the happy meal and decreasing worldsuck
with this entire punishment idea this is
okay with you just whacks one leg one
leg just one and lick a cat and you'll
be done John I'll see you tomorrow
ha